Georgiy you did an excellent job playing
Beth Anderson perfect sisters tell us
who is Beth Beth is almost like one half
of the same person she's you know she
couldn't be any closer to her sister
Sandra but they've both had a very
difficult childhood
they've moved around their mother has
been a struggling alcoholic and they've
had to deal with a string of abusive
boyfriend so when we first see Beth
she's vulnerable and just trying to hold
everything together and hold herself
together and her sister together right
and some would say that maybe she was
more of the darker sister in some sense
but in many ways she had some strong
qualities that you see during the film
how much of your own personality did you
bring to her and how much of Beth is
nothing like you I think Beth's strength
I could only dream of having I mean the
inner strength that she finds when her
sister begins to crumble is near admire
Ville and but I definitely could relate
to her her vulnerability because you
know at times we all face challenges and
that was something that I really wanted
to kind of show that you know she's
constantly trying to overcome things and
you know for me as a person I've never
had to overcome anything like Beth but
we've all faced challenges that we've
had to deal with so that was probably
something that that I could that I could
relate to and also she has a massive
capacity for fun you know her and Sandra
constantly you know just wanting to have
fun and escape into this fantasy land
and you know that's something I can
definitely definitely relate to well
there's a very real chance that all
three siblings could see the film and
your interviews what would you want the
real Beth I know her name's been changed
once released from prison to take away
from your performance that's a very
interesting question I think I would
just not want her to be upset in any way
by the film as long as she would be able
to watch it and feel
any kind of feeling you know rot except
for you know sadness you know I wouldn't
want to upset her and that's certainly
not what I set out to do I set out to do
a film not a documentary I never read
the book by Bob Mitchell and I made a
conscious decision not to do that so
that I was taking my cues only from the
script and only from the character I saw
in the script so yeah right now we know
that you know you begin acting in a very
young age of living a drama group yeah
town yeah so was it your plan all along
to continue as a career as you have done
or did the Narnia casting change
everything oh the Narnia constant
complete change everything I mean I I
wasn't even wanting to be acting as a
child and just loved doing doing it in
my own time like as a hobby
you never thought about it
professionally but the whole nadya
experience just gave me this massive
passion for it and now I can't think of
anything else which would satisfy me
more I mean there's definitely other
things that I want to try I mean I'm
interested in writing and directing but
yeah acting will always you know be a
real real love for me after that
experience and what types of female
roles do you like to watch and other
actresses that's really interesting I
think there's definitely been an
increase in female led movies I mean you
know we saw a planchette except her
Oscar and say that you know where we're
finally starting to grasp that I love to
see strong women on on film but I also
really like to see you know strong women
who have a vulnerable side as well
because I think that complexity is where
you know reality lies and sometimes do
more characters can be shoved to one
side so it's great to see when there's a
female lead who has real substance